i was out in phoenix out there
the rally in the valley people are fired
up out there about their hoops team
and they're playing hoops out there they
got a lot of brothers out in the desert
and i think one white
and they hooping the hell out of a damn
ball out there i stayed at a
like this kind of sober living place
while i was there and it was
they had a like
one night they had somebody got in a
motorcycle
accident and they came to the door like
the police came and uh
and i felt kind of bad because the day
before we were all going to the gym
if you've never been to a sober living
sometimes when you're there everybody
you get in a van and you all go
somewhere together
because you just
that's who you are you know it's like uh
it's like a daycare but for adults
that
are
that would sometimes rather probably
have drugs than lunch
so if you're like lunchtime and somebody
shot up
it's like that sort of
camaraderie that sort of club style
style
and so um
so anyway we got there i got there and
uh because i went to this therapy thing
for a week to this like kind of
intensive therapy place because you know
me bro
i got uh
i either have something i either got you
know i'm always
put pressing the gas on that something's
wrong with me pedal you know
so i'm in that freaking hov lane bro
something's wrong with everybody you
know what i'm saying i'm bringing us all
aboard so anyway i'm at this sober
living dude they got um oh god they had
it's like you know it's regular people
if you ever been to one it's a real
hodgepodge of america
it's kind of like a lost and found
but
a couple more lost
it's lost heavy
and so i'm there you know i roll up and
uh they got a there's one guy 65-ish you
know
and whenever you ask him anything hey
man what's going on he's like just being
this this is just staying sober
just things over
what you're doing it is going to be over
this he would put his hands up like it
was like the police were
like every time you were like hey man is
there any milk out of just being so
proud you know not from around here like
everything
was like i remember like one time i i
just asked him a question you know i was
like hey what's the weather like he
handed me his license and registration
so you know there's some real
you know america's top miscreants you
know it's a real it's it's regular folks
man
you know and i could have stayed in a
hotel or motel or um
hell i could have been homeless if i
wanted to but i chose to be
here there where i was
so yeah it was wild they had us uh uh
hasidic jewish dude i don't know if you
ever even
seen this
this guy
had on
like
all these coats he had like
uh he looked like he looked like
like biggie smalls
but
like biggie smallsburg kind of
like he had on like all he had on like a
a jacket it was so thick it was a
hundred and
probably 11 degrees out there
you know you could feel a [ __ ] i mean
it feel i felt like there was a dragon
outside
that's the
levels
of
air
heat
because the air will hold heat the air
is just really just a briefcase for damn
heat or cold
you know that's mother nature's
briefcase man
the air
because that's where she puts all of her
[ __ ] you know
but anyway so this fella man he was as i
mean he was
you know this little gimbal spinner was
about as damn jewish as you could get he
had on
he
he had on the hat the hat had on a hat
yeah like he yeah he uh
and if you haven't seen hasidic jewish
person you got to look it up because i'd
never seen it i'd seen it maybe
you know in the distance
i'd seen like one of these hj's at a
distance but i'd never seen up close
you know
and this fella he had on the head he had
on the dr the drapes the curtains he had
on a door
he had on nine it was he had on 19
layers of
clothing he had socks his socks were
wearing brassieres like he had i can't
even imagine
he was wearing about four loads of
laundry
and he shows up and he's like hi
[Applause]
and it was uh it was 119 degrees
and if you don't know anything about
hasidic culture
they can't drive
on
uh the sabbath
on like from friday sundown i think
until saturday sundown
so these fellas these bad boys and girls
they gotta walk
so this dude had basically
i mean he'd probably come from
mars
you could hear his like
his shoe or it was just whatever it was
just like
he's like hi
it's hot
like yeah it's hot man
and so every you know people's there but
you know it's a damn sober living some
do you know
one guy in the kitchen i'm like oh man
we're having dinner like this salad is
so good and he's like yeah it's really
good i was dead for 30 minutes two weeks
ago so
everything's good all right damn okay
bro
okay man down so you really
you really tasting this ranch
you really tasting
this fat free ranch today and you you
know
you're really enjoying and appreciating
and gratitude in that uh
that ranch
um
but this is so uh
it was cool they had like a little um
place to swim in the back and it was so
hot
the water you got in the water it was
like being in a um
it was like hiding in somebody's mouth
say you would
say you were playing hide and go seek
with people
and you somebody was uh had a heat
stroke
a real big person
big big so probably 11 feet tall maybe
six hundred pounds
and you hid in their mouth
during uh hide and go seek
and you hit in their mouth
that would be
what the heat was like that hot you know
somebody who had a heat stroke and was
also
um
they were late there was also somebody
was pouring heat on them
somebody had two bags of damn heat and
we're just filling them [ __ ] up with
it warming them
um
so that was wild uh
and then so the crazy thing is so we're
all going to the gym one day and this
one fella had gotten a new motorbike
and he's kind of coasting through the
red lights and just living life you know
and uh
and you know and i respect no helmets
because
the lord is looking for some people
and everybody wants to be alive and
everything and
and i get it but
we don't
know what it's like when you die
i mean it must here's the thing it's so
good i bet it's so good
nobody's coming back from it
there was a couple ghosts i think that
came back allegedly from the 1700s or
whatever
but then [ __ ] apparently they fixed
heaven up because
nobody's been coming back
name the last ghost you even heard about
you know ray charles maybe or somebody i
don't even know who
i mean he's not a ghost i mean he's
blind but that's
that's not a ghost a ghost is if you
can't see them so he's like a reverse
ghost
you know
but um
but anyway so we're out there we're crew
we're going to the gym in the van you
know
if you do sober living just you know you
that dirty grade school class you know
you're just that you know
you're a little more lost than fam
and so we rolling out
and this other fellow got a motorcycle
and so he's zipping in zoodad
and doing this and doing that and
stunting letting my daddy
and i tell the other guys in the van i
said hey uh
it's cr i said i used to talk about
organ donation
because my sister
make sure my head is all right
my sister got an organ when i was a
child
and she got uh
liver
she got liver and uh
which i wouldn't have got i would have
got two hearts
you know
you're like hey what are you doing i'm
like hey man throw another freaking
throw another pump in here you know what
i'm saying boy i'll be running hot dude
all the dance moves you could do would
you if he was double-hearted
uh
but but so anyway the um
the uh
so
so anyway this guy's skirting and stuff
and go we're all headed to the gym this
guy's skirting around on this on his
bike
and uh
and i say man guys you know i said he's
he's really
reckless you know he's a reckless man
out here
and
i said a lot of organ donors
the next day i come home
and uh
the
the fella
the police had shown up and the fella
had been in a accident
in a coma or comma
you know they're both pauses
and
and we're like
why
i'm like am i predicting the future
right now
so it was just
you know and i hope he's in i i you know
i need to check and see if he's i'm
gonna text somebody right now
see if the guy still comb it up
yeah i'm gonna see if he's okay uh
so
so anyway i don't they had a candlelight
vigil like on the third night the full
uh the fifth night
uh
it was cool we got to sit in there and
watch like some basketball games
together
and hockey
uh the canadians
you know those frogs bro i don't know if
anybody
follows hockey
but
it'd be awesome to cheer for the
canadians if everybody else in canada
didn't hate them
that's the weird thing
montreal is like kind of that french bad
boy you know
it's like everybody else is in a big
fight and then you got some dude over
there smoking a cigarette and sucking on
the freaking
on the
on the dirty side of a crepe you know
what i'm saying that back hole baby that
back jaw
you know
somebody freaking
uh you know sneaking into a crepe all
nasty from the back dude eat a crepe
from the front you creep
and crepe and creep is just one letter
different bro so if you want nasty eggs
dog get em french you feel me
get em french
praise god man
and then the last day i'm there the uh
hasidic guy shows up hello
this dude had i mean i don't think he'd
ever seen reg non uh
sids you know non
um hasidic people because it's a real
tight cult it's basically like
they're like the uh
they're kind of like the financial
native americans kind of you know
they're real
or i don't they're like man they're real
religious
like way religious
like i was telling my friend josh wolf
about it and he said that hasidic people
don't even consider him jewish they're
like
you got to be
in there
but that guy they gave him a chapstick
somebody and he never used it
so for the next oh like 14 hours this
dude is over there just going hard bro
just going hard on some pink lemonade
baby
he had that pink lemonade chaps taking
everything about every nine seconds
you'd look over and he'd be like
[Music]
dude that dude i think he
by the time i left and he had chapstick
his whole face
he had chapstick his he just couldn't
stop man
you know and thankfully we're all you
know everybody that's in the places had
some issues with addiction so at least
he's in the right place now
but and also
at least if the sun hits him now out
there he'll have a little bit of uh
of a block on him
you know
because that's
hello
dude it was anyway
it was needless to say it was a wild
week
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one